وفي تقرير يعكس ايضا رغبه امريكيه في
ابقاء الصراع عند حدود معينه نقلت وسط رجل
عن مسؤولين امريكيين ان واشنطن عدلت سرا
قاذفات صواريخ مارس المتقدمه التي قدمتها
لاوكرانيا حتى لا يمكن استخدامها لاطلاق
صواريخ بعيده المدى على روسيا وبحسب
المسؤولين فان هذه الخطوه بمثابه اجراء
احترازيا ضروري للحد من مخاطر اندلاع حرب
اوسع مع موسكو ومنذ يونيو الماضي زودت
واشنطن كياف ب 20 قاضي صواريخ من هذا
الطراز ذي القدره العاليه على الحركه
وبمخزون كبير من الصواريخ الموجهه
بالاقمار الصناعيه بمدى 50 مللا تقريبا
وسعدت هذه الاسلحه اوكرانيه على ضرب
مستودعات الذخيره همم الروسيه والامدادات
اللوجستيه ومراكز القياده على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه لكن التعديلات التي اجريت على
المنظومه تشعلها غير قادره على اطلاق
الصواريخ التي يبلغ مداها حوالي 200 مللي
بعكس هذه التعديلات المخاوف الامريكيه من
توقف الشريك الاوكرانيه عن الوفاء بوعده
بعدم استهداف الاراضي الروسيه باسلحه
امريكيه كما تعكس مخاوف واشنطن من حصولك
يافا على الصواريخ من مصادر اخرى واستخدام
المنصات الامريكيه لاطلاقها